Okay, so, good. We've got one, each person, we know how much they spent.
>> Yup.
>> Next we want to know, at the festival, how much money have we collected.
>> Yeah. So, in order to be able to display that, we need to create a report.
>> Okay. So, I'm going to click Reports.
>> Yup.
>> Think I'm figuring this out, Sam.
>>
[LAUGH]
And we want to create a new report.
>> So, I'll click New Report. What do I do next?
>> So these are mainly all off of the
standard objects, but we want to use our attending object.
>> Makes sense.
>> So.
>> I'll quick find it?
>> Quick find it.
>> Activities with attendees.
>> So, those are part of the solution
>> Yeah.
>> package. So, definitely not those. I, I don't know if you
remember earlier when we were creating the attendee object, how those little
check boxes at the bottom of the edit screen.
>> It sounds vaguely familiar.
>> Yeah. So one of them was to be able to
report on that object, so we'd need to check that box.
>> okay. So I'm going to go to attendees, and view the object itself.
>> Yep. Now a little bit different from before, we're just
going to edit the object completely. So just click that little edit button.
>> Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> This looks familiar, right?
>> It does.
>> Yeah, so right there, optional features,
allow reports.
>> Makes sense. Save. And then
>> Now
>> I think, yeah, I'm just going to go through and
do this for all the other stuff we might want to remember.
>> Sounds good.
>> So like what, festivals, bands?
>> Festivals, bands, stages, sounds good.